Traducteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous parler de transparence,
de la transparence en général,
que ce soit la transparence philosophique,
la transparence en politique
ou la transparence en technologie.
La transparence fait naître
une sérendipité.
Une sérendipité particulière.
Cette sérendipité arme des foules qui
s'en servent un peu partout sur internet.
Elle va détruire beaucoup des marques
qui nous environnent.
Et elle va détruire les marques,
en s'attaquant à notre imaginaire.
Parce que notre imaginaire,
c'est le territoire des marques
qui nous entourent.
Je vais vous faire une petite
démonstration.
On va prendre un imaginaire :
Vermeer, peintre baroque du 17e siècle,
qu'on connaît, a priori, tous.
Et là, vous avez une marque,
qu'on connaît tous aussi.
Une très vieille marque, elle a 41 ans.
Elle nous accompagne, tous,
depuis quatre décennies.
Et je vais vous montrer comment,
avec un peu d'imaginaire,
on peut détruire une marque.
En pratique, ce n'est
qu'un géant de l'agroalimentaire
qui fabrique, dans une usine,
des yaourts.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec l'artisanat,
encore moins avec Vermeer.
Cette petite chose que je viens de faire
et qui va définitivement
vous poser question
à chaque fois que vous allez revoir
une publicité de La Laitière,
cette petite chose, des meutes
d'internautes s'en saisissent
quotidiennement et, sur internet,
vous martèlent des messages inattendus,
de la sérendipité,
de façon à détruire des marques.
Cet été, vous n'êtes, probablement,
pas passé à côté de ça,
qui vous a rappelé que toutes les marques
ont une dimension politique.
Et n'allez pas écouter les politiques
qui vont vous dire
que c'est la faute à internet,
que c'est la faute aux réseaux sociaux.
Les politiques sont les premiers
à utiliser la transparence
pour régler un problème critique :
la confiance.
Quand une intense crise de confiance
a touché le monde politique français,
la première chose qu'ils ont fait,
c'est voter une loi sur la transparence.
Ça n'a pas beaucoup marché,
mais les politiques ont oublié
une dimension de la transparence
qui est précisément
que la transparence procède
du déterminisme technologique.
La transparence peut aussi être utilisée
par des experts de la technologie,
comme réponse politique.
Vous connaissez tous Wikileaks
et vous n'avez pas manqué
de constater que, depuis Wikileaks,
on ne compte plus
les modes d'action politique
qui procèdent de la transparence
pour imposer une réalité
et détruire un mensonge.
Et ça ne vous aura pas échappé non plus,
que Wikileaks s'est accompagné
d'une foule d'internautes.
Cette foule d'internautes,
c'est les Anonymous. Anonymous,
c'est quelque chose
d'absolument passionnant,
parce que c'est le premier véritable
mouvement social du 21e siècle.
C'est un mouvement spécifique
au 21e siècle,
au même titre que le syndicalisme
était spécifique au 19e siècle.
Au même titre que le syndicalisme était
spécifique à la révolution industrielle,
Anomymous est spécifique à
la révolution numérique.
Et depuis l'affaire Wikileaks,
les Anonymous ont accompagné
tous les grands mouvements
de protestation sociale,
que ce soit dans le monde arabe,
que ce soit ici, aux États-Unis, à Berlin,
à Paris, en Chine, à Istanbul
ou en Amérique du Sud,
les Anonymous ont accompagné
tous les grands événements
qui ont marqué les populations,
jusqu'à très récemment, en France.
Anonymous est très intéressant,
parce qu'il préfigure
les contestations sociales du 21e siècle.
Et ces contestations sociales vont
s'opposer aux États, on l'a vu,
mais également aux entreprises,
car Anonymous s'est déjà opposé
à une multitude d'entreprises.
La plus connue d'entre elles,
c'est celle-ci.
Quatre ans avant que Sony soit attaqué
par Kim Jong-Un et
ses redoutables pirates,
(Rires)
quatre ans avant ce triste épisode
qui vaut très largement
Saddam Hussein et l'anthrax.
Sony s'est fait attaquer
par d'autres types d'ennemis,
dans ce qui s'est avéré être
un véritable Fukushima digital.
Sony s'est attaqué à Anonymous,
aidé d'un autre groupe de hackers,
nommé LulzSec.
Et LulzSec a procédé
à une opération très simple :
ils ont pris ce qui était, auparavant,
de l'ordre du secret chez Sony,
des numéros de cartes de crédit,
des logins, des passwords,
et ils les ont rendus public, rendant
possible une multitude de piratages.
Parce que les utilisateurs de
Playstation Network,
ils sont comme vous,
ils utilisent le même login,
le même password partout.
Dès que j'ai votre login, votre password,
je peux aller partout :
votre compte Amazon, Paypal,
l'intranet de votre entreprise,
et si vous travaillez à la CIA,
c'est un vrai problème.
Alors, ça a eu des conséquences
dramatiques pour Sony.
Là, on voit un cours de Bourse
de Sony sur 3 mois.
Dans un premier temps,
il y a eu Fukushima.
Forcément,
ça a fait beaucoup de dégâts,
aussi sur leur cours de bourse.
En second,
il y a eu Anonymous.
Et dans un troisième temps,
l'arrivée de ce fameux groupe
de hackers, LulzSec,
qui a instrumentalisé, en quelque sorte,
Anonymous, instrumentalisé les foules.
Si on compare ça au Nikkei, l'équivalent
du CAC 40 sur le marché japonais,
vous voyez que, dans un premier temps,
Sony et le Nikkei suivent les même cours,
et dans un second temps,
eh bien ça décroche.
Et si on fait le bilan, eh bien, Sony a
perdu 3,5 milliards dans cette période
sur sa valorisation boursière,
dont les 2/3 sont imputables à Anonymous.
Au final, ce Fukushima digital aura coûté
à Sony 1,7 fois Fukushima.
C'est colossal.
Et dans les éléments qui se sont
dégradés dans la valorisation de Sony,
au premier plan, il y a sa marque,
la marque Sony,
parce que figurez-vous que les marques
sont valorisées en bourse,
au même titre que les entreprises.
Une partie de la valorisation d'une
entreprise en bourse, c'est sa marque,
quand elle porte, évidemment,
une marque connue du grand public.
Le problème, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
nous rentrons dans un monde
où la marque, c'est
le talon d'Achille d'une entreprise.
Les marques qui sont valorisées en bourse,
on ne les compte pas,
il y en a une quantité
absolument astronomique
et leur prix peut parfois
atteindre des sommes
qui sont complètement folles.
Apple, cette année, a dépassé,
largement, les 100 milliards de dollars.
Au total, si vous prenez les 100
plus grandes marques au monde,
on est sur une valorisation totale
de 2,9 trilliards de dollars :
une énorme bulle.
Une énorme bulle constituée
sur une relation
entre un capital de marque
et un capital de confiance.
Ce capital de marque, il se calcule
de façon assez scientifique,
étonnamment,
sur la cohérence entre
les pratiques d'une entreprise
et les valeurs d'une marque.
Et ça, c'est précisément ce que
vont attaquer les foules.
Et elles vont les attaquer sur
des lieux que vous connaissez tous :
Facebook, Twitter,
des choses comme ça.
Vous tous, vous avez un compte Facebook,
peut-être un compte Twitter
et peut-être avez-vous croisé,
il y a 2 ans, cette sérendipité-là,
quand le Rana Plaza s'est effondré
au Bangladesh,
tuant des centaines
de femmes et d'enfants ouvriers,
et qu'au milieu des gravas et des cadavres
on a trouvé des étiquettes Benetton,
mettant en valeur l'incohérence totale
entre les valeurs portées par la marque
Benetton et les pratiques de l'entreprise.
La marque a disparu.
30 ans de communication
jetés à la poubelle.
Vous n'avez pas pu passer
à côté de cette sérendipité-là,
lors du scandale de la viande de cheval.
Là encore, des foules
qui s'arment de sérendipité.
Et dans le monde arabe,
vous n'auriez pas pu passer
à côté de cette sérendipité-là,
durant tout l'été,
qui a provoqué un effondrement
des parts de marché de Coca-Cola,
dans tout le monde arabe.
La problématique, aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'on est sur une entreprise
qui est, de plus en plus,
dans une relation avec sa marque
qui est inspirée de Dorian Gray.
On a, d'un côté, une marque, publique
belle, jeune, dynamique.
De l'autre côté, une entreprise qui est
rarement publique, rarement jeune
et rarement dynamique.
D'un côté, on a des valeurs,
de l'autre côté, on a des pratiques.
D'un côté, on a un imaginaire de marque,
de l'autre côté, on a une réalité.
D'un côté, on a des consommateurs,
qui sont une abstraction imaginée
par des publicitaires,
et de l'autre côté, on a des citoyens,
vous, moi, nous tous.
Personne, ici, ne peut être réduit à
un simple consommateur,
à moins d'une sérieuse lobotomie.
(Rires)
La problématique dans laquelle on entre,
petit à petit, c'est que
cette frontière qui existe entre
le public et le privé,
dont on a tous constaté le déplacement
avec Facebook
et l'usage qu'en ont les adolescents,
cette frontière, elle existe aussi
pour les entreprises.
Et, petit à petit, le domaine
du privé, de l'entreprise,
devient de plus en plus public.
Et sous l'impulsion
de la foule, petit à petit,
la vie privée de l'entreprise
devient publique.
Nous sommes arrivés, aujourd'hui,
à un moment où la révolution numérique
va forcer les marques
à appréhender la transparence,
à ne pas lutter contre elle, c'est comme
lutter contre la marée qui monte,
mais à comprendre et
manipuler cette transparence,
et en tirer parti,
d'une façon ou d'une autre.
La révolution numérique
va forcer les marques
à interagir avec cette foule,
plutôt que de la subir.
La révolution numérique
va forcer les marques
à intégrer cette fameuse sérendipité.
À la faire sienne,
à ne pas en être victime.
Et enfin, la révolution numérique
va forcer les marques
à partager l'imaginaire qui était,
autrefois, leur domaine exclusif.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)